welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and you have no idea how
excited I am to break down Netflix's
avatar The Last Airbender trailer I love
the show so much we all do and
rightfully so Avatar is amazing and
before you ask Earth bending unless I
can blood Bend if I can blood Bend then
water bending but you know I would
easily just be a villain in that
Universe regardless and I'm going to go
through this trailer and point out some
of the things you might have missed and
please Fang girl with me and tell me
what element you want to be a part of I
want to hear it all additional warning
right now just so you know I will be
spoil in a lot of things we saw in the
Animated Series be sure to check out
nerd rot. shop to check out our latest
and greatest and new rockstars merch you
can grab our shirt featuring the best
bubs Deadpool and Wolverine or maybe our
latest shirt featuring Madam web with
the greatest line from any movie trailer
in history grabbing some merch From Nerd
riot. shop is the best way to support
the channel and all the work we do here
at new rockstars plus and wear merch
right now I wear this pink one a lot
because I really like it and it's a
little crop top so you can see my little
tummy good okay let's get into this if
you're watching this I assume you've
seen the Avatar the animated series and
not the 2010 movie but for those of you
who haven't avatar the Last air bender
was an animated show from back in the
day like when I was a kid and I'm old as
hell now in this world not everyone but
most people can harness the powers of
different elements earth air Fire and
Water those elements and their people
live in particular Nations kingdoms or
Villages that have better terrain for
their particular bending but one person
can harness all four elements known as
the Avatar whose job it is to bring
peace to the world the series centers
around a young old boy Avatar named Ang
who disappeared and was found 100 years
later after the fireing nation had
already conquered and ruled ruled with
the worst murderous grip it's his job to
now bring peace but no one knows he
exists the fire nation's trying to kill
him and he has to fully learn and Excel
in all the bending skills quickly to
save the world did I mention he's also
like 12 years old okay that is the
quickest recap I can give you guys so
let's get into the live action trailer
the Fire Nation is embarked on a dark
path and the world might never
[Music]
recover the world needs the
Avatar we open the the trailer with the
biggest takeaway the freaking visuals on
this show Netflix put the whole bag into
these visuals my faith has been restored
since the 2010 movie I will not be over
the 2010 movie never will be never
should be we open on these icy waters of
the North Pole the Fire Nation is
approaching this is one of their Royal
ships specifically Commander Z's ship
from season 1 episode 19 this ship is
bigger than the regular Fire Nation
Fleet and he has this giant golden tiger
Figure Head for his ship in aula has a
giant figurehead decoration as well the
Royal Sloop if you seen the original
series you know they're about to invade
the water tribe the narration is dung by
Monk yatso voiced by Lim KES Su this was
Ang's mentor and inspiration a really
sweet funny man who was murdered when
the fire nation invaded the southern air
Temple he's very important to the air
Benders but especially to Ang he's
narrating the imposing Doom that comes
with the Fire Nation and this pseudo
introduction narration was done by qara
and the original series and we'll see
her soon then we get a glimpse of our
favorite Flying Bison APPA APPA might be
the most important character in the
series if you love cute animals so pay
close attention APPA is Ang's loyal
companion whom he bonded with for life
they met when he was a young little
bison at the air Temple and he was
everyone's favorite he's the reason we
go yep yep he's usually everyone's mode
of transportation but he's also great
during combat because he's a giant bison
most animals in the Avatar Universe are
spliced with something else or just
random creatur so he's not the first we
see and certainly won't be the last
below Opa we see the trail of burnt
Woods that follows this is from season
one episode 7 of the Animated Series we
learned in this episode Hey by The
Spirit of the forest whom we see later
in the trailer has been lashing out as a
result of what happened by the Fire
Nation and is furious that the forest
will never return to what it once was
this is a reminder along with this scene
how important nature was to everyone
especially the avatars it wasn't just
their gifts they recognized how
important the land was to everyone and
everything then we see the attack on the
air Temple by the fire nation that I
mentioned unfortunately where gatso
passes in the animated series The
Southern air Temple felt smaller this
one looks dense and beautiful we haven't
seen this scene in the series and it
will be one of the most devastating
scenes to see it's the genocide of an
entire people there's a reason why Ang
is called the last air bender for a
reason the Fire Nation wiped out all the
air Nomads without a the air Benders
would have been completely gone oh I
never really thought about that which is
really sad sad to say if Ang just was
never
unfrozen they would have been gone
forever The Producers mentioned in an
interview how important it is to see the
scenes that were never shown in the
series so this means we might see the
attack on the earth Nation Uncle irro
losing his son more azula's training
while Zuko was away and so so much more
we could learn more about Jet and his
family this is huge for us and going off
these visuals will be delicious also
those aren't Fireballs those are people
imbued with flames flying into to attack
the air people all people with elemental
powers don't really fly more so hover or
Glide the fire Benders would sometimes
launch the M themselves up with their
fire but I think a big takeaway here is
that Ang said you couldn't get to the
air Temple without a Flying Bison and we
just theorized from that but I guess in
the rise of Kyoshi Pathways to the
temples existed that you could take by
foot but we just didn't see that so in
this series they can show us something
different it looks like the fire
nation's just going to be flying up
there with their fire jets the Fire
Nation didn't make their airships until
after the battle of the Northern Air
Temple so like season 3 so they wouldn't
have had them yet in this series The
narration says the world needs the
Avatar and if this isn't already
heartbreaking to to hear and witness at
the same time then we get the sickest
Glimpse at fire lord soan and look I
hate this guy but man is he sick in this
scene like come on in the Animated
Series yeah he sucked he killed his best
friend but this guy looks so good in
this cut it's insane some may think this
is Uncle iro but I think this is before
a and during the attack on the air
Temple so this is most likely the
slaying of monat and God damn in the
Animated Series we saw the dead
Firebender soldiers and then monat's
body so he was running through all these
guys until he couldn't do it anymore and
I kind of don't want to see that scene
play out but we got to see it we got to
see it the producers want to show us
what we didn't see before Lord soan was
the ruler of the Fire Nation and started
the hundred-year war with the goal of
taking over the entire world he's
basically like Queen Elizabeth or
Isabelle of Spain look at his armor
which is impeccable the details of the
dragon and the Flames are I'm eating
this up the visuals again they really
laid into here there are original animal
Benders for every element so like
dragons represent the Fire Nation Badger
moles for the Earth Benders and Sky
bison for the air benders but the water
vendors had the moon which I don't want
to really get into right now because
that episode messed me up and we'll
probably see it in the first season then
the contrast from bright red to blue
transitions us to the scene of the
century season 1 episode one The Boy in
the iceberg aka the release of a the
newest Avatar well he was already an
avatar he's just being re-released from
the ice that he was in in the Animated
Series qara broke the iceberg and Ang
floated to the surface trapped in the
ice when he was released a gust of air
blew qar and Saka to the ground and
there he was for those that haven't seen
the orinal series Ang ran away from the
air Temple when he knew his training
would move him to the Eastern air Temple
he and OA got caught in a storm that led
to crashing in the water and he uses air
and water bending to freeze themselves
and use the Avatar state to survive fast
forward to now he's basically been
frozen during the entire war and that's
where he went when he disappeared it
looks the same here but the visuals are
stunning and according to Netflix's
trailer breakdown with the cast this was
the first day of shooting who have
thought I love how many scenes from the
trailer we've seen in the Animated
Series so far because it's all so
amazing and it makes my breakdown more
fun then we're welcome to the Shady dark
corners of of the Fire Nation and we
meet Daniel Day Kim's Fire Lord
oion this man looks damn good this is
our current ruler of the Fire Nation
also Zuko and Zula who we see in the
next scene's dad io's brother and a
master at fire bending truly the worst
person you want to go up against I love
that he has almost the exact same look
including the hair with the fire piece
the narration continues this time I
think by Katara like in the original
series intro saying the Fire Nation has
destroyed everything in its path so oai
has continued doing what his father
started then we get a great look at
Gordon cormier's Ang he montio as qara
and Ian osle as Saka and the outfit's
again incredible I love it you can make
out even Kara's necklace the symbol for
the water benders qara and Saka are
siblings and Saka has no bending
abilities but qara does additionally
they're Ang's biggest supporters and
best friends on the topic of wardrobe
and costume all of these looks
throughout the trailer work so well and
look amazing I didn't know if they could
do it but I was proven wrong the
attention to detail with the designs for
their particular Clans are so
tantalizing to look at the waves on
guitar's coat the fire designs on Zuko's
armor I'm obsessed with the color pops
they look like they did in the cartoons
it looks so good you guys behind them
there's a giant explosion slightly
Illuminating green I think it's a bomb
or something combusted that isn't a
bending person because we don't really
have green Flames unless it was from Ron
and Shaw from season 3 the dragons then
we cut to the Earth Kingdom and they
ostrich horses opposite of them we see
Prince Zuko of the Fire Nation being a
little butthole Prince Zuko is played by
Dallas Lou and is the heart of the Fire
Nation at the end of the day so we can't
really hate him too much and I know he's
going to be a pain in the ass at the
beginning but I promise he gets better
we cut to the southern air Temple 100
years after the fire attack this is
probably the scene we get in Season 1
Episode 3 which will also be when Ang
finds the body of monat and has a minor
breakdown he feels guilty for not being
there when all the attacks were
happening luckily qara helps him through
it I hate the despair that comes with
these views but the ivy plants that get
the stretch and climb all over the
buildings it feels like the environment
is just restoring itself then we get a
glimpse of katar and Saka home wolf Cove
or Capital City the center of the
Southern water tribe I'm obsessed with
the look here and ice blocks with the
chafed Harden white indents I'm just
obsessed with this set it looks amazing
back on Oppa to the left of Saka you see
Momo Momo is a winged lemur and another
loyal companion to Ang they find him
when visiting the air Temple after its
destruction and so far he might be the
last winged lemur left after the Fire
Nation took down the air Nomads we're
overlooking Kyoshi Island we'll be
seeing Koshi Village later in the
trailer and this might be one of my
favorite places because it's home to the
Koshi Warriors a group of warrior women
who protect this island then we get a
riding a ball of air and crashing into a
statue like a little idiot this is a
direct call out to the intro sequence
where he does the exact same thing
because he's a little boy he's a big
Goofy dummy I like how in this one he's
trying to impress people though cuz
basically in the other one he's just by
himself running into statu January can
be cold and dreary which means it's a
great time to crawl into a bond charge
infrared sauna blanket Bon charge is a
holistic Wellness brand with a huge
range of evidence-based products to
optimize your life whether you want to
sleep better have more energy or just
de-stress which is where infrared sauna
blanket comes in Bon charges sauna
blanket raises your heart rate so you
burn calories while you relax to help
your body release endorphins and leave
you feeling relaxed and euphoric ooh
euphoric it's super easy to set up Heats
quickly and so now you can get the same
relaxing benefits you would from a while
reading a book for 40 minutes on your
couch get him
darling Bond charges infrared Sonic
blanket has free shipping worldwide and
a 30-day free trial so you can test it
out risk-free go to bond charge.com neww
rockstars and use coupon code nr15 to
say 15% off that's b o n c h a rge.com
neww rockstars and use coupon nr15 to
save 15% don't think I didn't notice
that ball of cabbage Saka is holding now
the Cabbage Merchant comes with the
greatest lore to Avatar history he's a
simple man who sells cabbage that will
continually be destroyed or damaged by
anyone and everyone all the time he can
never be successful and I think he is
going to be making an appearance in the
liveaction series the Cabbage Merchant
usually did business within the Earth
Kingdom so this scene of Ang impressing
people might be linked to the Cabbage
scene and were're currently in the earth
Kingdom we open on Zuko's ship as he
sails the icy Seas near Katara and Sak's
home Zuko is searching for the the
Avatar and we learn in season 1 episode
12 that it's because he brought so much
shame upon himself for not wanting to
fight his father they banished him to
search for the Avatar and only then
could he return with his honor his ship
was also just as crusty in the Animated
Series leaving clouds of smokes in its
tracks then we see a close-up of Uncle
iro in Zuko's bedroom on the ship iro is
played by Pauls hyong Lee now if you
don't know Avatar iro is the Zuko W gatu
was to a he was almost that fatherly
Mentor he needed iro is occasionally
very funny and silly but usually looks
out for Zuko which is always needed the
producers of this series with IGN
mentioned we spent a lot of time with
the Fire Nation in the first season more
than they did in the original series
which I love if you saw the Animated
Series a lot of the history we didn't
see or stories we missed was because it
was the Fire Nation because the focus of
the story was on Ang and the Gang plus
Zuko then later fans Started Loving aula
T Ruki and these other characters and
Other Stories and the lore became so
tantalizing I'm glad that they're taking
this approach because it feels like
Scott Pilgrim takes off and how he
literally took off maybe not to that
degree here but you know you you get it
you understand on Zuko's Pepe Silvia
board we see photos of a and what I
think is the volcanoes that power the
Fire Nation it looks like that volcano
that Zan fought next to the bottom of
the volcano you see a fan this is
probably Zuki of the Kyoshi Warriors the
beautiful world of the map we also see
in the intro of the Animated Series I
assume blue is the North and South poles
for the water tribes red is the Fire
Nation white is the air Nomads and
yellow is the earth kingdoms I
translated this as best as I can and I
think it reads Co Ying mini custards
there may be facilities and activities
nearby a must have for Hong Kong's
natural habitat already got the message
firstly egg custers was a tart found in
Chinese cuisine and we see them serve
them up in the earth Kingdom they love
them so did the air Nomads this was one
of Ang's favorite foods secondly it
shows that his journey searching for the
Avatar he's recognizing the other
nations resources and is like mine give
me and the producers spoke about the
series being Japanese inspired how the
locations and influences in the world
are based on real world indigenous
cultures and Asian world so it looks
like here the Fire Nation owns Hong Kong
and pushing it to build upon it Hong
Kong is basically the Republic City in
Avatar which was founded by Zuko and Ang
eventually in the Animated Series during
like Legends of Kora I think currently
it's claimed by the Fire Nation after
they invaded the Earth kingdoms you can
see the brown curve on the map that's
highlighted that is where Republic city
later we get a glimpse of the back of
Zuko's room and I love that the walls
are decorated like the red scales of a
dragon then we see the outfits of the
Fire Nation soldiers aka the fire Army
the outfits look identical to the
Animated Series but more metal which
makes sense because they mess with fire
for a living they also have these curly
shoes we see them in especially Zuko and
these bad boys throughout the first
season their arm is also built with
non-bending and firebending soldiers
Zuko mentions getting the Avatar is his
Destiny and this scene really reminds us
how much of a mission it was to appease
his father and make him proud Zuko was
on a mission in the first season to not
go home empty-handed then we see Zuko
and Uncle iro I imagine the scene is
connected to the one where they stopped
the ostrich horses here we go again on
how cool the visuals are in this show
Netflix is really cooking with gas on
this one according to the Avatar
producers they really tried to make
everyone's bending look different but
also with different sound designs iro
bends you'll hear almost a dragon sound
underneath the bending and now I'm going
to be eating this up more then we see
the horrible though insanely hot Fire
Lord oai good Lord I need an ice cold
shower after this one I need to cool
myself down cuz this man is hot
regardless though I'll be thinking about
this forever this scene is incredibly
important and horrible this is the rise
and fight Zuko scene so this is the Agy
Kai that happens in season 1 episode 12
Zuko prear goes into the war chamber and
is told not to speak up in this meeting
and without even thinking he speaks up
about something that wasn't right and
was sentenced to an annai with his
father this is a fire duel that's only
one once the other opponent burns the
other imagine an old-fashioned duel Zuko
bowed to his father during the duel and
his father burned the hell out of his
own boy this is the mark that's left on
his face and the reason why he's
banished this happens around episode 6
according to the producers and we're
really going to get into the core of
Zuko's story and journey I hate when we
even see him bowing to his father this
scene was so sad in the series that you
start feeling horrible for Zuko because
these kids suffer from abusive parents
and their parents affection is directly
tied to their success and it's just a
shame in that episode where we learn
about the agnik kai was Zuko's father we
learn the history of Ang when he talks
to qara it feels like this scene here
while Zuko was taking responsibility for
his actions Ang is too Ang in the series
kind of fell under pressure a couple of
times but his friends kept him up in the
first season I think he gives up a
couple of times especially by episode 19
then we see Ang and APPA embracing more
than a loyal companion he's like family
during this Saka says this you don't
have to do this world you have me Tara
and a flying ball ofer what more do you
need I will say this trailer does do a
good job emphasizing the importance of
the Avatar team throughout all the
series this is something that so strong
and you have to see it to understand it
these characters will support each other
through all the saddest moments that
will tug at our heartstrings and don't
get it twisted they fight too but each
brings a different quality that always
brings them back together also their
kids look at them what's not to love
about the little Avatar team and here is
the queen in charge June played by Art
and show and Nyla June is a bounty
hunter who always had her companion ass
sh you named Nyla Nyla has Superior
tracking skills scent detection and a
venomous tongue that paralyzes you Nyla
and June are introduced really late in
the first season when Zuko enlist her to
find the Avatar so this is probably the
beginning of their search additionally I
love how Nyla looks she looks like a
little mole monster thing she looks
amazing then we see a using his air
bending staff which unfolds into a
fanlike glider we saw him use this a
couple times in the Animated Series as
well we see the hey by spirit that I
spoke about earlier in that episode of
The Avatar this Spirit steals human
villagers in retaliation for the
destruction of the forest so this
episode is going to be horrifying and
the spirit will likely be kidnapping sck
then we have a shot of the Kyoshi
Village that man is Ken lung playing
Commander Xiao who was leading the
attack in the Animated Series it was
heavily Zuko and he didn't really
succeed earlier in the last episode
before they attacked the village Zuko
challenged Z to an agnik Kai and he beat
him but I wonder in the series if they
maybe say that ziao beat Zuko this time
or Uncle iro interfered again this scene
could be many things I'm just not seeing
Zuko there but you can see the Kyoshi
Warriors right here scene that Koshi
Warriors as their fans is so cool
because they are not Benders they are
non-benders and they still kick more
butt than any of the Benders they're
extremely ruthless combats that you
don't really want to go up against they
use their fans to Fan the Flames from
the fire Benders also we haven't seen
much of it in in this trailer but Saka
has his Club it's made of a polar bear
femur and fixed with a sphere at the end
it's just a blunt weapon he uses in the
Animated Series we can also see it being
used here this is the city of amasu the
second largest city in the earth Kingdom
we venture here in episode 5 where we
meet the craziest king that's ever lived
I'll get to him soon because he's in the
trailer you can't really tell because
it's so quick but the person gliding in
front of Ang is Tio Tio was introduced
in episode 17 of the first season pretty
close to the end he can keep up very
well with Ang gliding and his dad
designed his glider chair if it isn't
obvious by now the gang like Hey Arnold
touches a lot of people's lives and a
ton of characters tag on to the game for
short bouts of time or help them when
they sto by so we should expect to see a
ton of
people I'm the Avatar and I'm going to
save the
world so in this scene we see the blue
spirit in episode 13 of the Animated
Series Ang is captured by Commander Xiao
and the blue Spirit frees him in this
incredible scene truly this scene is
already looking super cool I love it we
cut to Opa dropping Ang on board Zuko's
ship this scene is during Zuko and Ang's
first encounter fighting at Saka and
katara's home during the first through
second episode of the Animated Series
he's using his staff to blow back the
fire Army later we see him taking on
Zuko one-on-one and this is the very
first encounter in half the world
doesn't know or believe that the Avatar
is truly back yet kutas Saka Now using
what I think is his boomerang I also
didn't think he got this until later in
the second season but I don't think it
hurts to get it early he throws it at a
fire Army soldier and I like that the
metal when it hits the helmet created a
spark okay I know I said it a million
times in this trailer because every
scene is my favorite but truly this is
one of my favorite scenes and my
favorite character this is the king
Boomie of omashu he's literally just a
crazy person and I love him he's an old
friend of Ang's and he puts Ang to the
test and fights him the reveal that this
old man is actually built and will
stretch himself into the strongest Earth
Bender alive is just so funny and that
reveal is so good to me the Wardrobe
matches and the underground chamber is
stunning and I said it once and I'll say
it again these visuals are killing in
the next scene we see qara and Zuko
fighting this is the end of season one
in the animated series The Siege of the
north it has two parts now remember how
I said the producers said they want to
make everyone's bending look different
that's the beauty of qataris how she
moves so synchronized the Tai Chi it's
fluid and the blast of water exploding
into ice against fire shaping it into
different chaotic tendrils of rope about
to like eat up Zuko guara is an
incredible fighter no one in her Village
wants to go against her she's phenomenal
and of course she's beating that ass be
for real Additionally the producers
mentioned how everyone bending underwent
extensive training before shooting their
scenes the core cast went through about
six week boot camp where they learned
martial arts and they learned the
different bending techniques even if it
wasn't their own technique they had to
learn all four all Avatar Bing Styles
look different but they're also created
from different traditional Chinese
martial arts styles of combat that's
what the producer is speaking to water
bending is influenced by taichi it
requires a clear mind and relaxed body
to get better results it's not so much
about the skill but how you move and
connect with that fighting Earth bending
uses move inspired by hungar a style of
combat that focuses on the low stance
and being grounded fire bending is
inspired by the northern Shaolin it
highlights long range techniques quick
advances and Retreats it's aggressive
and explosive like fire but fire can
also be fluid air bending was inspired
by bwang it uses a lot of open hand
attacks they're better at evading and
counter attacks using circular and
spiral motion then we're introduced to
our young person this is jet another
character from the Animated Series he
was introduced in episode 5 it was
titled after him and I had a crush on
jet like every young girl did when I was
younger he was really like the
heartthrob of the show when he lifted
qara up to their Treehouse I said one
day that will be me jet worked with the
Freedom Fighters a group of refugee
Earth Kingdom children that mess with
the Fire Nation troops cutting off their
supply lines and ambushing them jet
fights with his Twin Hooks they have
long hooks at the end and he knows how
to use them in
fights
we see Ang begin to light up and this is
the signifier he's going into the Avatar
State this is the ability that avatars
have to channel a ton of cosmic energy
and knowledge of the avatars before them
this in part gives them the increased
strength and power while bending they'll
have access to all bending techniques
and Ang so far in the series didn't
really show up until this point that he
could control the Avatar State I don't
think he even did in the very very end
it's hard to control we're regardless
you know if you see him getting into the
Avatar State you better move because
it's like going Super Saiyan I love that
the producers say we won't see a go into
the Avatar State as much as he did in
the original series this season because
they want to convey how important and
serious it is and I agree that's a great
idea because imagine just going full
Phoenix Force every other episode would
it be scary anymore then we close the
trailer with the four bending element
emblems the water bending symbol is the
same design as qatar's necklace Earth
bending fire bending then air then Ang's
Arrow Illuminating the title The Last
air bender and that is it for my
breakdown on avatar the Last Air
Bender's newest trailer there are still
some characters we haven't officially
met like my favorite character of all
time which is probably why we see so
many Smackdown scenes because she's not
there yet I love love love the series as
much as the next Millennial I love this
show I hope you do too it's a super fun
rewatch and three seasons go by pretty
fast I promise if that's too much that's
also fine wait until the end of February
to watch the live action if that
enlights you then go back and rewatch
The Animated Series I'm sure you have
like one friend that will watch it with
you if they don't I will follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Lulu Clemens
follow new rockstars and sub subscribe
to new Rockstar for more analysis of
everything you love check out the break
room and the Deep dive yep
yep